coucou je suis fan de casse-tête des
années j'en fais sur la chaîne je sais
plus trop lesquelles choisir et j'ai
demandé à Loïc de m'en sélectionner un
comme ça ça la surprise je le découvre
avec vous
tu vas voir il est vachement bien il y a
un truc à l'intérieur donc j'imagine
c'est il faut retrouver ce qu'il y a
dans la banane ouais ok alors ça soit
c'est un fake soient ça permet vraiment
de la première étape ok
pas mal
c'est ça que faut trouver oui bravo
tu as été super laisse-moi deviner c'est
toi le créateur
en vrai je me doutais que ce serait pas
terrible donc je vous en ai prévu un
très beau ça c'est un labyrinthe vous
voyez ça bouge faut faire bouger une
bille qui à l'intérieur il y a des
miroirs dedans
j'adorais se faire ce casse-tête en
vidéo je vais le faire que pour moi dans
la vraie vie je vous mettrai quand même
des images sur Instagram j'ai déjà
partagé un story l'autre jour parce que
c'est un film c'est pas possible alors
puisque ça passe pas on va passer sur un
classique créateur
Jean-Claude Constantin the wave box il a
l'air incroyable il est très très beau
il a été fourni par les Amis de la
soluble je vais l'attaque wow attends il
s'est déjà passé un truc là non c'est
bon j'ai réussi à le mettre à zéro tu
sais quoi pour bien se poser avant que
la vidéo commence je vais vous proposer
un cadeau enfin c'est pas moi c'est le
partenariat de la vidéo qui va vous
proposer un cadeau ok avant de continuer
laissez-moi vous informer que cette
vidéo et sponsorisé par Audi ne Fabien
c'est quoi déjà audible écoutez je vais
vous le dire bonjour c'est une
application de livre audio et de podcast
qui proposent plus de 700000 titres à
télécharger c'est simple audible propose
à ce jour le plus grand catalogue de
contenu audio qui existe il y a ça par
exemple dedans et comme par hasard le
grand plus c'est que vous emportez votre
bibliothèque partout avec vous et vous
retrouvez ainsi vos histoires et des
auteurs préférés même hors connexion
suis-moi Loïc bien par là dans le bus
dans le train dans le métro partout où
vous pouvez être à capter Internet et
bien vous aurez vos livres audio dans
votre poche quand même c'est bien si par
exemple mon dernier livre votre idée va
devenir une réalité et bien elle est
disponible sur audible donc vous pouvez
l'avoir avec vous a et alerte bon en ce
moment audible vous propose une offre
spéciale de 2 mois sans engagement si
vous inscrivez via mon lien donc vous
pouvez tester la plateforme télécharger
les contenus qui vous intéressent le
plus pour voir si ça vous plaît comme
tous mes livres que j'ai lu moi-même et
si jamais ça vous plaît pas aucun
problème sachez que vous recevez un mail
pour vous désinscrire 5 jours avant le
renouvellement automatique de
l'abonnement donc vraiment vous pouvez
tester l'appli sans crainte vous l'avez
compris audible veut vous accompagner en
ce début d'été avec des livres audio et
autres contenus dans vos oreilles avec
une offre sans engagement alors
rendez-vous sur le lien dans la
description pour en profiter et vous
allez pouvoir découvrir plein de titres
dont votre cerveau est extraordinaire
votre temps est infini le bonheur est
caché dans un coin de votre cerveau
l'antiquité de la manipulation mémoire
vous allez pouvoir ou l'excellent votre
idée va devenir une réalité parce que je
les ai tous lu moi-même ils sont tous
dispo sur audible c'est l'occasion d'en
profiter avec l'offre sans engagement
voilà bah j'espère que ça vous plaira
parce que mon dernier livre audio c'est
bien moi qui le lie mais en attendant on
est sur les wave box de Jean-Claude
Constantin c'est parti on va se faire ça
je pense qu'on en apport quelques heures
le weekend
tu veux y aller OK
ouais alors par contre Lolo
si tu peux laisser la caméra
concernant tout ce qui est filmé le
casse-tête c'est mieux quoi
ok c'est bon Fabien je te laisse ça si
jamais ne m'appelle pas ok box de
Jean-Claude Constantin est noté sur le
site de l'insolube meilleur site de
Castel en France 6 sur 6 la définition
de 6 sur 6 c'est un bouffable
c'est un truc dans le genre on se fait
la phase d'exploration mais là pour
l'avoir déjà tenu dans les mains je
crois qu'il y a pas grand chose à
explorer je crois vraiment que tout va
se passer là vous avez vu ça commence
déjà à bouger d'ailleurs avec les
espèces de vagues déjà je pense que la
première étape ça va être de passer les
billes là le but annoncé c'est d'ouvrir
un comportement secret j'imagine que
c'est lui mais rien n'est jamais sûr et
Constantin alors on a les trois billes
on a les trois vagues d'où la Wave
machin c'est un petit peu sombre mais si
je suis comme ça vous avez le reflet
c'est pas terrible il faut que je sois
bien synchro pour les faire descendre en
même temps ah ouais ah waouh ok bon ben
on vient de la comprendre la difficulté
comme c'est pas les mêmes vagues je peux
pas les faire descendre au même rythme
je sais pas franchement peut-être mais
un comme on n'a jamais vu mon pote
vraiment un comme on n'a jamais vu je
vois même pas comment on va pouvoir s'en
sortir mon ami là je peux pas le tirer
parce que lui il est arrivé dans cette
courbe là
[Musique]
de me dire que là c'était une très
mauvaise idée dans ta messure parce que
déjà je suis capable de le remettre dans
son sens initial parce que elle il
faudrait dans ces cas-là que je la fasse
descendre un peu plus en fait il faut
penser par courbe les trois je pouvais
les faire descendre là après j'ai poussé
ça m'a poussé du coup
je peux pas la remettre si ça m'a poussé
ces deux-là je n'arrive pas à les faire
repasser toutes les trois au même
endroit oh ok donc là ça m'a fait
descendre elle un peu plus bas
du coup je peux faire descendre comme ça
ok vous avez compris le principe en fait
j'ai annulé la vague en remontant un peu
pour essayer de faire descendre des un
peu plus c'est de là si je les fais
remonter j'arrive à prendre la coudée et
après je peux les récupérer toutes les
trois un peu plus en gros là pour passer
cette coupée faudrait que j'arrive à
tirer encore plus par là donc faudrait
que lui soit ici c'est je crois que
c'est ma seule manière pour qu'il soit
plus par ici il faut que lui j'arrive à
l'emmener plus par là donc peut-être que
je fasse remonter elle avant
comme ça non c'est pas assez parce que
j'en ai un qui bloque c'est lui qui
bloque c'est celle-ci qui me bloque ça
demande un peu de muscle moi j'avais pas
prévu d'avoir des muscles non redescend
pas à toi
et donc lui je peux le faire descendre
d'un cran ok lui j'ai réussi à le faire
descendre jusque là du coup puisque j'ai
réussi à le faire descendre jusque là du
coup ça me bloque pour lui là j'ai
besoin de pousser plus c'est qui qui
bloque cette vie qui bloque et lui
encore une fois qu'il bloque lui je le
fais repasser par le haut là je le
redescends là OK et donc là si je fais
ça les trois passes ok waouh c'est un
séquentiel en fait le qui avait raison
c'est clairement un séquentiel là je
pense que je l'explique mal juste vous
me voyez souffrir de toute manière je le
vois bien à la fin des spectacles vous
me dit refais des casse-têtes et je dis
mais pourquoi parce qu'on aime bien te
voir galérer ça c'est votre réponse ce
n'est pas très plaisant si ça me fait
rire mais après il y a peut-être une
autre étape ensuite je sais pas en fait
combien il y a d'étapes parce que la
boîte est quand même bien fait
Sylvie je le mets là lui il faut que je
le fasse descendre plus donc pour le
tirer plus il faut que lui soit là mais
pour que lui il soit là il faut que je
pousse encore un tout petit peu avec lui
soit en haut pendant que lui est en bas
comme ça voilà tac ok faut vraiment
raisonner avec froideur faut pas
s'exciter sur ce truc c'est ça le plus
dur en fait dans ce genre de casse-tête
c'est parce que tu as envie que ça
avance et puis il est terrifiant parce
qu'il paraît simple je crois que c'est
pire les casse-têtes qui paraissent
simples parce que je crois qu'on a tout
un autre disposition là sous les yeux
maintenant je veux que ces deux-là ils
passent ça donc il faut que je puisse
tirer plus dans ce sens là pour tirer
plus dans ce sens là faudrait que lui il
soit plus bas mais pour qu'il soit plus
bas j'arrive à pousser là maintenant le
maximum que j'ai c'est quand ils sont
là-haut les deux donc j'avais raison il
fallait d'abord que tu es con ah non
Fabien ne bloque pas le casse-tête on te
connaît tu vas t'énerver
allez allez petit petit allez
j'ai de la boule qui est coincée
Loïc
bonjour monsieur oui la tête la tête oui
la tête la tête voilà ok donc là je les
ai bien replacés ces deux là en haut ce
qui me permet de pousser plus et donc
d'emmener cette bille là jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout en tout cas aller dans son
truc du bas donc lui je peux le faire
descendre là comme ça comme ça ok déjà
là j'ai plus que ces deux-là à penser en
temps normal lui il va avoir quand même
une incidence voilà ok j'ai ma séquence
tac tac tac
là maintenant il faut que je tire plus
par là pour faire passer lui donc il
faut que je l'emmène tout en bas pour
l'emmener tout en bas faut que lui qui
soit plus par là
donc lui je le remonte à sa position
initiale oui je sais que tu ne vois rien
Loïc oui oui Nancy ça va là je pousse
donc là lui ça me permet de l'emmener
jusqu'ici il est censé passer non lui il
est attends pourquoi il descend pas lui
il faudrait qu'il soit dans le vide lui
non bah non non il faudrait que je
remonte cette bille là
il faudrait que je recommence cette
ville
donc c'est remis la une et la 3 à la
place qui m'a fait perdre ce qui m'a
permis de descendre la deux complètement
comment ça va avoir une hypothèse c'est
qu'il va falloir que je descende la
trois complètement et pour ça faudra
remonter la 2 et donc descendre la 1 tu
as compris
[Musique]
un grand moment de vidéo pour vous
tu es pas mal ça exactement comme prévu
vous avez vu j'ai fait une magnifique
descente Loïc ralenti s'il te plaît de
la descente elle est magnifique après
cette descente mais le plaisir
évidemment d'avoir évolué devant son
public et là je me retrouve bloqué ici
et pour pousser à cette pointe il y a
qu'un accès c'est cette bille là haut et
cette bille là haut c'est la merde très
agaçant donc d'abord il faut que je
remonte complètement la une
OK et maintenant pour continuer à
pousser il faut que je remonte elle ici
qui est le seul endroit qui me permettra
de pousser ce bois contre cette bille
donc pour ça pour refaire descendre la
une
[Musique]
ça rigole pas c'est pas rien en fait
donc on remonte la 2 là elle doit passer
là dehors elle passe donc maintenant que
j'ai remonté là deux faut que je fasse
remonter la une
oui oh bah là si tu voyais l'image je
pense que ce serait pas ton plus gros
problème la tête lui il est pas prêt
pour ce qui va voir dans les rushs je
vous le dis voilà là tu crois qu'il voit
bien les gens moi je suis pas sûr qu'il
voit bien ah là vous voyez un peu ah là
il voit bien la légende dites-moi dans
les commentaires si vous voyez malin
c'est important de me dire ok j'ai
remonter la une et la 2 comme vous avez
bien pu suivre dans la vidéo qui me
permet maintenant d'appuyer ici de
passer la troisième tout en bas pas mal
parce que si je comprends bien
maintenant je peux faire redescendre la
2 en jouant sur La Une et ensuite la une
ça devrait être chill à la toute fin
donc je me concentre que sur la 2ème
[Musique]
là ah non c'est classe de remonter ça ça
me permet de descendre une complètement
parce que j'avais pas le choix pour
passer cette dernière vague il faut
remonter la ligne complètement vous le
souvenez donc la une vient de la
remonter donc la 2 elle passe OK allez
la une on y va oui oui
en bas
une bille de billes allez viens la
troisième
ok les trois billes sont enlevées
j'enlève le petit panneau je le je le
dépanne
et compartiment secrète compartiment
[Musique]
elle fait des petits pots de confiture
c'est incroyable ou pas
Loïc range ta chambre s'il te plaît
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis mais je l'ai mais j'ai envie
de crever quand je l'ai fait par contre
un casse-tête un casse-tête bien fait
c'est un casse-tête un casse-tête qui
est remis dans l'autre sens pour le vous
le faire gagner sur Instagram il y a ce
poste que vous découvrez maintenant et
je vais vous faire gagner parce que
c'est pas rien je crois qu'il est d'une
valeur de 210 euros quand même ce petit
on va vous faire la toute fin en méga
accéléré donc vous pouvez rester jusqu'à
la fin de cette vidéo parce que à la fin
on va vous faire un truc avec Loïc
incroyable
en plus
[Musique]
franchement j'ai mis combien de temps
Loïc
sans caméra
ah mais oui j'avais un micro ah mais
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable mais
j'ai rien vu venir j'espère que
vous êtes content de m'avoir bien pranké
aujourd'hui n'hésitez pas à bénéficier
de l'offre de diable qui a dans la
description pour avoir pour avoir le
jeton gratuit je sais plus c'est un mois
ou deux mois on l'inscrit comme ça à
l'écran et comme ça vous pouvez écouter
par exemple mon dernier livre votre idée
va devenir une réalité et tous mes
autres livres d'ailleurs en audio que
j'ai mis et voilà ça vous fait ça vous
fait de la gratuité pour écouter mes
livres en audio on peut pas faire
beaucoup mieux que gratuit non ça joue à
gagner sur Instagram merci à l'un seul
look casse-tête si vous cherchez des
bons casse-tête c'est chez eux et nous
on se voit en spectacle pour les
quelques dernières dates la d'archétype
ça fait plaisir allez je sais pas
pourquoi je fais ça avec mes mains Ciao